I spent the last three months going from
being somebody who thought they would
never want a 3ds to pretty much falling
in love with mine it's actually gotten
to the point where I forgot next-gen
just to spend a little bit more time
with my little gold pimped-out three yes
I've got a few reasons why I recognition
- so for today's episode of the jist own
thing blow off the ps4 and the Xbox one
go spend your hard-earned dollars on one
of these for any of you who are looking
at me like I'm crazy in this little
Internet window let me start off with a
really obvious reason Nintendo's epic
franchises Nintendo may have struggled
massively in the hardware market of late
especially when it comes to that console
which shall not be named but their first
party games are simply awesome Nintendo
has brilliant game worlds built into
sprawling franchises and they haven't
let any other platforms get a look-in so
since you're always going to have to
pick yourself up a Nintendo branded
console to get in on their lovely
franchises I'd say the 3ds is your best
option right now I'm not opposed to
trading it out for my n64 now and then
but it's possible that the latter is
getting a tad dated given its almost two
decades old alright so that's an easy
one but another reason you should
consider buying a 3ds is because of how
far the console has come a lot of people
lost interest in the 3ds very quickly
after its launch in 2011 because it was
well awful the launch games were
atrocious the sales were down the toilet
and it only took six months for the
device to get a huge price cut down to
169 dollars from its original 249 not
only that but Nintendo was so
embarrassed they offered gamers who
bought it at the original price 10 free
NES games and 10 free Game Boy Advance
games so that's the bad part but the
story really does improve from there
nintendo went on to release the 3ds XL
in mid-2012 which while stacked up
against the more appropriately priced
original and the child-friendly 2d s has
resulted in 42.7 for
million units being sold worldwide
numbers aside there's a reason the
console worked its way into gamers heart
and that's because Nintendo worked hard
to make every facet of the device better
not to mention packing on a stack of
very impressive games Nintendo certainly
do make some decisions that make you
wonder if they actually know their
audience at all but there is one thing
they're very good at incorporating and
that's backwards compatibility yep I
talked about this in my video on how
Nintendo will sell we use this year and
it's pretty apt for this segment too
that the radios will chug on happily
with most of your DS games although it
won't go as far back as Game Boy Advance
stuff the resolutions can either be
scaled and stretched or native on the
3ds or 3ds XL depending on whether you
opted for the biggest screen my
second-to-last point is pretty simple go
handheld with a great piece of hardware
my cam here is about 20 minutes and most
of that it's walking so unless I want to
run into pedestrians while liberating
lorule I couldn't ever really see the
point in earning a handheld console but
I was mistaken
mostly I game on my PC occasionally my
ps3 and very very occasionally my Vita
but when I got my 3ds to play link
between worlds I actually found myself
sitting in my living room to crack into
it or sofa gaming which I've never been
able to do given I mainly mouse and
keyboard bound I've always figured the
screen will be too small and the
controls finicky but the 3ds XL is built
beautifully the world's can be as
immersive as console or PC games and
everything is undeniably smooth as a
piece of hardware the 3ds feels
excellent and runs perfectly with a
timing intensive game like link between
worlds you notice really quickly if the
hardware isn't up to snuff and a 3ds
works like a dream the last and most
important reason is that the majority of
gamers are buying consoles because
they've got the best lineup of games and
the 3ds has a killer selection this
point is the culmination of all my
others the smooth controls the epic
comeback and the beautiful French I
2013 particularly was an incredible year
for 3d software from Animal Crossing to
Luigi's Mansion dark moon Pokemon to
Fire Emblem awakening there are many
games that landed on the 3ds last year
what even specifically portable game of
the year worthy they were right up there
competing with the best of the PC and
console games and at least four games
but one of these epic games even took
out our ultimate game of the Year pick
this system is definitely not what it
used to be and definitely deserves
another look if you've been skeptical
its loads of fun exceptionally refined
and features one of the best gaming
lineups ever to be packaged into a
single console
I'm totally converted let me know what
you think as for the hard games that I
talked about on last week's episode you
guys were all pretty much on board with
Battletoads being insanely difficult but
grim a gangster wanted it noted that
just because the selection of games is
harder doesn't necessarily make them
better and I'm right there with you a
lot of you also wanted to pass on
special mentions to The Witcher 2 on
hardmode and Vees which is also on the
3ds so consider it done thanks for
leaving your thoughts and I will see you
next week